my ice cream like chocolate I like pizza
and cheese like a dude is hurt ain't
dance night dance Steven I just got
dance oh my god
[Music]
so welcome to worst fire team ever
podcast number so hey all right so let's
start off let's talk about summer so I
talked about singing oh the ghost the
actual does that matter to you
dude these are the house at the house
just a sick way in the guiness dusty
please and go Steve go here that lives
in here well you don't think you should
go see I think it's just I don't think
it goes I think it's just your neighbor
why no no no but I can't Steve I'm like
dude we've been living here a long time
we've never Central it's on the side but
why would it why would the ghost just be
pissed off at them maybe that's cuz it's
Colin's old unit it's callings ghost he
was not he they weren't the first ones
to live there and nobody else it's not
him it's some other old ghost that's
[ __ ] with well here was a thing you
told me that the shoe okay this shoe was
in the dog's bed there's dogs living
there and Steve said in a [ __ ] closet
and the dogs it's impossible for the
dogs to open the closet for the dogs to
get to the shoe and you said it was up
to your neck but seriously it was like
that's all you saying the dogs are that
you're saying the dogs moved it I think
the dogs got the chute
that's what I said at least I did you
saw me kidding me you're taking the side
of the dogs I'm just saying like I just
it's a it's a shoe in a dog bag and it
the dog is about the height of where
that she was yeah that was interesting
what you want to talk about our place
being haunted right you think our place
well if you think that's gonna add to
our destiny podcast yeah that's where
you play destiny no we talked about all
right there's a 93 year old neighbor
named Colin Drake is old Hollywood actor
who died and now his ghost is haunting
our places
he's moving keys and moving off just say
your place is so old that it's just
rickety and it's falling apart every
time you hear like you know it's just
and he is the point very your place is
the Temple of Doom we do live in a
trashy place our place is land good
enough so there okay what do you want no
okay this goes back to the overall about
Tess this is clear and they actually are
really good friends
- nice there's no problem killing um so
here's the thing so going back to is cuz
we talk a lot not just about destiny
when we play list yeah we do talk about
a lot
movies wants to be my nobody you know so
I so I guess the funny thing is the
other day we talked about ghosts cuz you
think the place is haunted
well yeah the only one you're not the
only I'm not saying you know the
neighbors due to weaker neighbors our
neighbors Diego strange yeah who they
live in : they also hosted Steve's party
yesterday there's a really nice people
nice people crazy they're not there no
but they they did this thing where they
have been seeing weird things and the
weird part is like okay so they thought
they had a key that they couldn't find
and then all of a sudden ended up in the
door right was that yeah
outside the door right so really they
left the key in the door when they got
home and then closed the door and they
couldn't find a key oh there's another
situation where I'll go back to so why
was funny as then Steve says to me Steve
says to me like they had a shoe okay
better suit yeah sure go from there
Klaus in their closet that moved to the
doggy bed and they had two dogs okay
it's all the two dogs when they came
back from Craig's the two dogs were
walking towards the bathroom afraid to
go over there when they walked over to
the bathroom the [ __ ] bathtub water
cables just just turned on on its own
right right the bathtub did the biggest
thing I feel like though especially with
like what goes it's like a snowball
effect when someone what would someone
see something and it takes him out are
some snowballing it's when you start
creating things they may sound like the
shoe fell well here's the thing is like
so Steve says to me the closet of those
yeah well here's the thing
Steve says to me the closets heavy and
you can't open the door which that's
arguable could it come might have been
cracked open but then he said the shoe
was up here and so I go there and I was
all right it was down
story you didn't seem like it was like
now is the funny part of like cuz you
get scared and some was ice worst ghost
story okay
yeah but this part of it because we're
talking on things we talked about so I
was saying like the ghost in deci where
he talked about this in destiny said I
don't believe in ghosts that's what
Griffin said oh you said that yes okay
so I'm saying I'm just talking about
stuff we talked about
okay so then another thing I was gonna
say is like me and Griffin and we're not
against specific beliefs we have a lot
of we have a lot of political bring up
nonsense you know bring up something so
we have a lot of political people go
like you just did with him with it don't
what you do and like okay so from from
our standpoint when when you when Christ
starts getting on do it about politics
that's when the chat guys oh yeah
nobody's talking nobody Riverdale I give
these there's an idea he wants to touch
on in the world he'll touch on it but
like you'll it'll end I'm just saying
that the main thing is party when we
talk about boom boom one day we can you
watch yeah we were doing and we got
yelled at I was trying to remember who
yelled at oh yeah I left at that point
yeah you got a pill but I think it was
gathering horror that's like you're an
art they grow right that's what we do
you don't come into our thing and tell
that's time I'd like to do kind of play
right right that was done that way it's
funny is because like even though we
bicker and argue and debate like it's
still like our debate space and
conversation space
yeah and sometimes a great space you
know sometimes teammates know better
your girlfriend she's a girlfriend
effect on you I give it you think about
things differently yeah joe said i'm
playing destiny at all yeah I think it's
really passive but no one gets off
that's true it's been rough lately
because so now this goes to the beta
because now that Destiny's two is coming
out yeah there's no offense there's not
like anything to pull let's discuss
something more important here yeah is
neither I nor Steve enjoy debater I
don't like this game this game just I'm
just enjoying myself this is just that
same feeling I get like I'm shooting my
gun at the guy that shooting his gun at
me
but I'm dying and that person got you
know 80% health I just don't get it
what how's this guy still alive
like nah dude oh god damn it I just
can't with this game yeah this this
games now this or this one I know dude I
know what you mean not know what they
give me the same that same [ __ ] Wow
my shield when I see this I don't know
what it is I'm never gonna be good at
this game
like ever I'm somebody like trying to
get into the NBA and I just like you
know I'm like no matter what I do I'm
not gonna be able to [ __ ] play this
game well yeah I'm really hating it it's
the same [ __ ] but but but but what don't
you like about them but in defense of it
what it is it would be like if we're
playing destiny if we were playing
destiny with just the gunsmith guns yeah
that's what it was and that wouldn't be
fun though the gunsmiths guns are stupid
yeah and then visit I mean you can
disagree but I've been because my girl
plays overwatch and what I felt like was
they took all the cool things from
overwatch and just implemented into desc
well my only argument with that and this
is where I fell astray like the [ __ ]
wall the Titan [ __ ] wall that you put
that's yeah but I think as a nerd only
the fallen dude it they stole that from
the father
yeah but let me get back even before the
junk rat well what's that new [ __ ]
launch I don't get that funny the
grenade launcher the way you shoot it
seems like joke rats TV here's what I
get frustrated and I'm not defending
anything I think overwatch is a great
game but Bungie has been making these
games since the first before the first
half that's true that's true Bungie has
been made a halo and all and so in
marathon pretty much most of any mall
FPS is steal from each other okay but if
anything I mean overwatch took from
Bungie
I mean Bungie I saw hey I went to e3
with my buddy Chris back like when pelo
first before it came out on xbox one of
the best games yeah and we waited to our
gunner [ __ ] pistol with a scope yeah
the pistol and the first Halo was the
most overpowered
oh absolutely rear sight a low similar
no no but going back to it we waited two
hours to see that at e3 and it blew my
mind because it was on PC it was before
an Xbox I tell ya and it was like you
could see the bullet trail it's like I
remember it so vividly and you can ride
in cars with your friends you know what
I mean stuff like that now we take for
granted it was like really ahead of its
time back then so like when so it's not
that I disagree with you I think they
steal from each other but I think that
they're just they're trying to find the
new format I mean dusty twos gonna come
out as gonna know we were playing that
crucible stuff I thought oh it's the
same [ __ ] but like the same thing where
you can't even use your rifle is a power
weapon but you get you got it you gotta
think of it this way though because you
you think that's stupid
but at the same time when the game comes
out and you get your try hards and
crucible it's gonna be the same it's
gonna level the playing field how am I
gonna have to use price they all have to
deal with the time the hill is longer so
it's more focusing on and it kills
longer you know
[ __ ] five hours to kill one person
but okay but you guys talked about being
frustrated when you get just completely
[ __ ] on it's gonna be harder to get
completely [ __ ] on you come running now
yeah you you oh yeah you can run and
like I said run a primer how many people
in Destiny's shade step with a shotgun
and never use their primary how many
people sit in their spawn and camp with
a sniper I can't do that [ __ ] because
the ammo because because I saw the power
house and you can't even revive they
have people and not only that as much
with the power ammo now only the person
that picks it up gets it yes all a team
can't just horde one spot wait for ammo
and then get a bunch of ammo and run
around the shop I if I if I'm in front
of the heavy door I'm in front of the
heavy and he's behind me I have to wait
for him to show up and then they can
both grab get the power ammo there's a
coupon well let's just go over like the
things with the positives in the
negative okay positives I thought was I
like I looked I have I'd really great
and I thought the gameplay was smooth so
I liked that part about I just like that
you when you're shooting you really feel
that's one thing I about destiny anyway
overall feeling like whatever you're
doing it's doing it and once he's good
at that yeah that's why hey Louis yes
also like the thing though is like even
when you get to the same gun the feel
feels different even if it's the same
guy it depending on the perks yeah I
mean like yes you can play like
different what to what this does need to
are those yeses okay this new one it's
still carried over I feel like forget
about like the multi twist the saddle
joking it feels it's also the Sarah no
that's what say it's also like gunner
doesn't feel every yard has yes every
gun has a different sound yeah yeah so
no point that they did that it was like
a percocet that's why I spent $5.00 on
the game guys yeah but I mean then again
I mean this is literally a snippet it's
a beta so like every they're already
adjust I don't hope so yeah I mean there
are you adjusting things and also like
you have to think about this one when
you when we were first playing destiny
you didn't even I didn't know the
subclasses literally I just thought it
was boring though that strike you do
yeah I agree with don't worry I agree
with that I thought the story was kind
of like whatever football yeah I mean
that but it was a snippet but going back
to like it when we first start playing
testing like blink we you know you
change like you more put the game your
game play more plus Morris with the game
because like I remember i was using
Monte Carlo then when they switched it
over bodies got right I want stop
Scott's because it was more stable and
yeah you know yeah like you auto rifles
worth it
right and they meant to pulse rifles and
then you bought two auto rifles back and
they made a more and I think that's the
thing that's just like its balancing and
finding your rhythm and like what works
for the game now even you know I can't
say it's gonna be great because we don't
know boy what I like about the two
primary slot like having an energy and a
primary what's cool about it is it's
gonna it's just gonna make it more
diverse because though they've already
said they're I mean they're putting more
weapons in the game but you say that
every time they do but all I know I
think with that style
you're constantly gonna be switching
between to two guns yeah and what I like
about that what I feel like they did
good is and they explain this in a video
every gun has its purpose
yeah but there's no idea roles it's all
gonna be the standard same role gun
everyone gets well in there doing our
new roles there no there's no roles
worth anything this is what does it's
all gonna be the standard this [ __ ] you
can this is which is not cool well this
is what they're doing though yeah
they're doing it so I had a problem with
that because I like the customization
exactly I like that reward of getting at
them right but what I like that's not
gonna head I like about it it's gonna
make it's gonna make the game more
competitive because you're not gonna
have people grinding and getting god ol
guns and then just running everything
everybody's gonna be able to say the
same [ __ ] gonna be menos kill base and
on top of it you get two adjustable for
us yeah you like you actually won some
of those for you you get when we played
you actually didn't win and Griffin got
you a lot of kills I mean I agree that
it's just different and it winning it's
about adjusted with into what they're
doing like for the customer Mayson side
cuz I like to customize their adding
weapon mods so like oh they are yes so
what you do with your primary it has a
troll right but essentially these weapon
mods there's a bunch of mods and you can
run for whatever mod that you want also
that'll be the same thing and you can
you can fix disability so you can adult
with one thing yeah it's pretty
much like there's a perk you want vision
oh they got that from that's what
division doesn't do you say I'm telling
you the vision is great - it's like such
a puzzle it's so funny I bought it got
him into it he hated it at first you
hated yes hey 30 wasted his money and
then he got balls
I still play I'm playing more than
deafening yeah well that's me right now
is like I didn't know the monster came
out right because everybody wants to
play the second right baby is coming out
and I'm like you said but they didn't
have very much content at all a lot of
people's issues was well it takes so
long to get my mail in and what is it
come from and what is it coming out
beside number six six also by the way
that means it's already came out like we
just like right when this comes out and
this comes out what I've already or does
he even the playing field by I just how
do you think trousers gonna be for it
why don't they make the strikes for
that's a good question but here's the
other thing that bothers me though about
that like like I like multiplayer of 66
I like cuz now we can't all play you
can't do she says we can't do six gems
that's gonna be and that's my issue
looks like a second one person good yeah
that's something I know I know I know I
don't like that part of it that part of
it but others but but they might choose
that you know this I hope they change
that because they've done that a bunch
of times where they've done this or
switch this or made this I don't know
why more people aren't complaining about
that because to me that's a first I mean
I mean there they are but from like the
PvP standpoint yeah and looking if I
gotta look at it from a game developer
they're like with destiny there's so
many moving parts there's always going
to be something people have issues with
but the reason they're kind of catering
towards PvP and making sure that it's
balanced is because like like Eric said
previously when all the end game content
is
done people are gonna play crucible it
turns into a competitive game with light
trial trials is what kept destiny alive
without trials people without trials in
the crucible hear that stuff because in
this side you already finished the story
so now what right then but then what
they found a way is like this whole
grinding it's like how every week it's
like all here's the daily because what
they added to the daily missions now is
that they added a burn and let me get
something so you makes you go all cow
play this again and then you get kind of
nostalgic when you play now because
you're like oh this is that mission from
what you call that we did like so long
ago what would I like because the way
they they said it yeah have you guys
ever played like Final Fantasy 7 oh yeah
ok do you remember like on the open
world Matt you you fought Sephiroth that
was then too game right now but then
they had the weapons which were like
crazy hard bosses that were harder than
the end of game content like they were
almost like you had to be like the most
powerful you would be that's what I feel
like they're doing with the Patrol
they're adding these lost sectors where
like you can go in but you need a
[ __ ] stack fireteam and it's hard as
[ __ ] so like there are handy too yeah so
they're added you find this information
if it's all over oh that's so like their
handle is it like an Archon force but
like everywhere yeah yeah there's him
there's like that there's like like like
little blade on it like World of
Warcraft you know in campus all together
yeah well I thought you can with four
right can you control the Traverse I'm
not sure but I know that there was if I
saw something the other day and I'm not
sure it was run into other people I
think fireteam more patrols still maybe
for it I don't know I mean I do but I do
still think that like for people playing
multiplayer stole iced
I wish they'd kept some of it six yes
for the fact that like more of us are
played well and I like I think I think
they did it because you know a lot of
people complain it like a lot of PvE
players
complaining because they don't like that
it's being catered to competitive pvp
but keeping a game will walk like around
for a long time right it has to happen
what I mean here's the thing like I get
like if you want to make the rain for
people cool because it was always so
hard to find the range still thinks but
but but you got you got to look the in
they put the clan stuff the in clan
right in the game now so like they have
matchmaking for raids right I get that
yeah they're finding that but that's
even but that was my point of playing to
do but you know what I would say there's
like long division
for instance they had this thing called
incursions and those would be like the
heart like that Billy equivalent to
destiny would be like the rains or super
hard slacks but what happens though is
that yeah yeah yeah because you can't do
this I think they just added something
in division right now they added a whole
new level of like we're like let's say
if you shoot somebody in the head if
someone else shoots that person in the
head
they'll it'll be instant kill so it was
like forcing people to actually work
yeah yeah forces people to work together
so I think that like that's the same
thing in like destiny where it's like
you know you you know so you plant a
raid of something you have to be talking
well well thank you the problem is a lot
of people that play destiny that don't
have the friends to do the race a lot of
people didn't do the rate so the reason
they added this and they added if you
would have had friends didn't get it
right right yeah but like that's what's
cool about this is they they they not
just like on your clan like you get you
get gear through your clan for doing
like deeds kind of and there's there's
an option where if you want that going
matchmaking and you help someone
complete a raid it tracks it and it adds
experience to your tally and then at the
end of a season it gives you crazy loop
well then you get loot for helping
people so it's going to make that it's
gonna make the community not as
tamoxifen it's gonna be yeah you know I
think that's where it's great I love the
matchmaking rate but going back so just
a regular PvP I still don't like that
for me I first I mean part of our lives
like right now we can't place it
we can't play Steam and you don't know
it's like later on though change that I
understand why they're going for
for the competitor I mean the good news
is Brad won't fall asleep early so the
crew won't be it won't be there right
now but I mean think about it with how
many people are gonna be on destiny -
right we'll have it when you stay in the
same part we can still be in teams of
warring for it yeah yeah it's not yeah
it's not as cool because we don't have a
lot of people though still these [ __ ]
are gonna be on all of them yeah of
course of course you know no should we
learn the hand cannon what do you think
will be the opie weapon there cuz I'm
trying to learn him Candice it's fun
though because when we we played the
beta right yep and once again Craig
Craig's trying to tell me about pulse
rifles I I actually got a little I got a
little annoyed about this because I owe
you
yeah no no he's like yeah what was the
name of the one used it was the energy
one it was an armada thank you no I was
using I said I said the nightshade was
better cuz they had better perks and
it's bad so it was I forget what it was
called the start they're gonna have
there's something but like I'm like I'm
telling I'm like Craig try the
nightshade he's like I don't like it as
much and then somehow we talk about he's
like but coke you don't use pulse rifles
I do I'm like so you're saying I can't
use Paul's right I got Reds on like
Steve oh yeah oh my oh my [ __ ] this so I
switched to nightshade with halfway
through the game I was 18 and
I'm not gonna do what am I gonna say
could we know coax the best it's like
you know what I mean is like Kobe it's
like on our team it's terrible
no but but we're I did kill them once
that monitor gets that but I did kill
when we did let you know Bailey Blaylock
and we did all melees engine kill Cove
okay so let's talk about that play
destiny
we did a matches with the annoying guy I
think the stinking your name that we
played a private match where we can do
nothing but Mae away okay so of course
okay I'm using this support this
community here I'm using I'm using a
killer I'm using a gunslinger a throwing
knife what are you throwing two of those
what kill unless I hit two custodians of
your names you're still alive but I trip
mine I'm just saying I can't shoot like
and a trip line doesn't do one hit kill
you I'm not being in the point so he's
got a sergeant angels he's Bryant you
later
he may like it you didn't win the other
guy won Vinny yeah but we both got we're
both scored higher I mean mine was like
14 and yours I was always the worst I
was the worst but because my class it
[ __ ] sucks there's no way I can kill
it there's no way I still take you one
on one Titan
really no no I remember we played a
private match in he peed
the annoying thing with Craig when you
want some place just one boy just
Roberts he doesn't use that don't you do
you run she's running one shoulder
charges in Craig's mind that he's doing
a solder time I know it doesn't even
matter cuz they get it so it's like well
they give the fusion name yeah but they
give did before I'm saying like they've
[ __ ] did since the beginning like cuz be
used to auto target a lot like used to
run and then I could hint dudes that
were turning laughter going right now
like Frank saw usually Don yeah you have
to be like right in front of them and
you have to hit him straight on and then
now in the new one again took like they
give too hard like it doesn't kill
anything but you know with your fist of
havoc which is equally good kids in it
suppose what they want people to do they
know wrong zoom or they don't know
waiting around corners but they don't
want hitting people they change that so
like then but the question though is I
after you do the show
it doesn't kill people are you so fond
but you're just gonna die right away and
usually yeah there you might be laughing
but that's the status of pointless
they're gonna have to fix that the thing
is the thing is what it's designed for
is you're supposed to make weaken them
with your gun and if you're about to
lose a gunfight then you can finish them
yeah but there's only don't you take
down the shield and then shoot see my
hands don't get up right yeah you can't
just you can't home from the zero to
shoulders your arse and they're already
shooting me exactly that was Mike and
he's like nothing they're gonna fix
there's no way they're gonna keep that
like that you know
but though let's go let's go to supers
cuz like here's one thing that I'm
pissed that you told me is that they're
bringing back a stupid stone call
they're bringing back all those
subclasses I thought just a second in
the in the base game we get three
subclasses for all yeah it's not gonna
be - well the warlock has a lot of
people somewhere to be - because they
only let us play - on the characters on
the beta and they kept it a secret but
then they just released that now they're
all of them stormcaller hammers and I
think they just added one new one that's
it don't well they the Warlock as a
slave played it off because when destiny
one came out we all got two subclasses
for each one yeah so the speculation was
that they were gonna do the same thing
and they weren't gonna add the third
subclass until the DLC but that's no
they're like we're gonna add there it's
gonna have aww we're gonna have all but
they got rid of one thing you're rid of
they got rid of our baby is a roaming
super you see we're over an elder but
when you say that it's weird cuz now the
super is now I know they're adjusting it
but they take longer to build yeah
you'll find out why our job is so so so
do him Alan that would they said that
was months old like that was a build
they knew that they were gonna put out
but it wasn't even the game of what they
haven't had at the point anyway so one
issue they had is everybody got their
supers and even if you're getting a lot
of kills you won't get your super
everybody got their number at the same
time at the end of the game so they
change that but you also got to take
into account you know people were
complaining about grenade energy
as much community but you got to think
in a betta none of the armor helped with
any like we have our verbs yes armor we
get your name back every 25 seconds so
we're used to that destiny once so when
we play destiny to we're like [ __ ] we
never have grenades yeah so they're
getting there's gonna be armor they it
was like it was like death but the beta
was like playing with blue armor yeah
yeah and good spins guns yeah yep yeah
so that's why I was coming and I thought
about that but at the same time it was
like I thought that the actual game the
game stuff was boring I thought that the
lake the PvE yeah yeah I thought this
party was boring and I thought that like
I even thought that the crucible stuff
was boring it's not the maps were too
small yeah I won would you do the flag
thing it was like a Figaro yes yeah yeah
yeah it's a little small area that it's
like after a while you're always doing
the same thing everybody's going to this
everybody's going to that spot so yeah I
mean and that's something you get like I
mean we'll just have to see whatever but
I guess there's gonna be more crucible
games you know cater not all but they
only gave you three yeah yeah so play on
the beta so we were just playing do you
think about the healing aspect what's
they kind of took from over 100 either
what I tell you one thing or the other
that overpowered weapon or you could
heal what I think about all the
abilities is like it's just kind of one
of those things like they want the same
game but they want to add do you want
something different yeah I don't it like
if you're gonna sell another game that
other people won't buy it if it's just
the same fun they're gonna yeah gotta
get new people yeah yeah what I like if
I didn't want to do this one at all
those what do you call it I wanted all
the weapons that the enemies had you
know like I said that's what's a so that
one bubble is just like that's what the
the the Fallen were using all the time
yeah are you shooting out of take in and
they put that bubble up yeah yeah I
think you know three they gave that they
gave that to you know the guardians now
that's all it is
I wanted those weapons I remember the
Lord of wolves shotgun oh but it was
like because they had that those falling
captains had that shotgun then tracked
yeah I was like I want that gun yeah
yeah
but I want to pick up straight up yeah
but uh but no other than that like even
though they are back on the abilities I
let it personally is a hunger I liked it
because I hate shadow fat I don't like
that so far so now that that is back
though it's back but like me I can as a
gunslinger the hunter ability I don't
waste em so I can shade stuff as a
gunslinger never real oh I realize but I
can't I can't you can't spam it yeah so
now people can't just [ __ ] like it
over and over
yeah it's definitely doable your mother
died now there's things where it's like
you know reload your gun I thought it
was underwhelming I was like this is
kind of weak for the hunter but I in PvP
it worked a lot it's time to kills not
not as high so like my dirt said you can
run shade step works really well for
like getting the [ __ ] that's one thing
go destiny like it ever first one you
have to fight and die cuz as soon as you
turn your back you're dead you're dead
yeah there's no escape alright I just I
don't write you never can escape yeah
that's why I like this you get to make
and they said this they said this
perfectly you get to make the call
whether are you gonna take the risk to
get a gunfight and try and shoot them or
you you have enough time to make that
decision like I got to get out of here
I'm about to die which i think is it
that's more of a skillful thing than
just going somewhere and there happens
yeah repeat judge you're [ __ ] dead
yeah you know what I'm saying I mean the
main thing to do is it's just new so we
have to get used to it I mean it took us
a while to get used to the first test
mean you did it like I said we were
talking about you guys didn't even play
I think I play with Griffin PvP oh good
I was so lame yeah you ain't just
playing that was anything and he really
like then and then Bob didn't either
you guys it's nobly never yeah for a
long bob into it because remember we're
all man we're okay but to me that's like
the biggest I mean that goes back to
trials I mean even though we're terrible
at it it's it's like but it's also like
the biggest win and the biggest loss
like if you lose in trials your own so
pissed but if you win it's like yeah
it's not to lose it in trials it's not
the losing
frustrating it's how we lose like
getting it's just like they just come
here like we're talking about like hey
let's do okay let's go right now is
heavy round yeah be round
if you daddy nobody got it forget rocket
launcher then the next round is they
have their super support their camping
and we we have to figure out yeah but
they're like on the other end and it's
just I hate anyone when I first started
playing when you were doing like you
know just the PvE stuff I would use a
hand cannon yeah cuz it was the most
powerful kind of powerful pace your
shots - I didn't know that I thought
yeah but now it's like boom the gun that
I thought that it never they never fix I
think the biggest gun I have a problem
is a scout rifle because if you look at
the damage that he's supposed to achieve
on a scout rifle yeah it's it's not done
properly well I feel I feel like cuz I
guards they have it all [ __ ] up yeah
because I'm a scout rifle if it's like
this high much damage right that should
be a two-shot kill yeah what a scout
right I feel like should we bet that I
feel like you know all the weapons that
be on the same the same what like level
like the hand cannons high the Stokes
and you know they should all be on the
same level I think they own just this
Calif we should have been more closer to
what a pulse rifle and waffle is
considering the damage that it actually
did right right I wasn't doing that yeah
I agree
and they they all right they changed the
loadout of the weapons they're
completely different now like the way
they bar it goes off energy like you
know how they have a kinetic energy or
they're all about that's how they're
separating the weapons okay so this is
what you'll have like submachine guns
involved yeah and this is this is what I
like in PvP this was actually a good
idea to so that you've got the the
kinetic and you have the energy weapon
they made it so energy weapons do more
damage to supers oh so like they do have
a solar weapon and you look is a solar
yeah if you want like an energy hand
cannon because like there's roaming
supers and hand cannons
damaging thing you can have that because
that soul like and it doesn't matter it
doesn't have to match what the subclass
is energy weapons in general do more
damage to supers so like so it's no it's
another judgment call like oh [ __ ]
there's a super coming for me on Swift
Ipswich into myeloma or should I even
get the get out [ __ ] right right right
well it's gonna be interesting to see I
mean it's just different gameplay I mean
we're gonna have to get used to it but
it's a fun game that's what we play it's
over hits and you're talking about it
you know missing like no I will say for
me though like the gunplay that's what's
integral about destiny that's where halo
also is like a master of where they
excelled right because like when you
play on their games there's like almost
a rubbery feel sometimes in the gunplay
or it doesn't like Halo and me I mean I
just II felt very precise yeah I mean
like thank you guys a shot you blame
yourself you don't blame the game all
the time don't be like wow like how did
I miss that you know what I mean like
that like so that's why I mean that
that's where they really excel I mean
aside from like you know playing
together there's nothing else that was
like always a big thing because the
weight of the gun felt good and like
yeah yeah and like a lot of games a lot
of games I liked overwatch but overwatch
feels very cartoony and yeah I would
change this thing where like you know
you're roaming around like like on the
Cosmodrome whoever you are you know and
they're like you go to another area and
then like you would it's like you're on
a new server
yeah like you feel loading up yeah yeah
yeah then like because you may be like
you know you might remember how it like
we were always trying to get like six
people at the corner boring like you so
now we found each other on a different
printing part we're like oh we did it
and then you start going yeah you
disappear right yeah it's so I just
wanted to get like a what the hell was
that what it was and that was like a
server change yeah because that was it's
like an world Warcraft there's instances
you know so you go to a dungeon that you
you're in the same dungeon but it's two
different three right right server yeah
so that's how it was you know you can
always tell cuz to be those long like
walks and stuff you could just show them
disappear you're like oh I'm in I'm in
between could I hit on that you know the
one thing I wish like that I know cuz we
don't pay attention to it but it's just
too much is the loading screens I wish
there was more of something or like
visual amenities what it is we're
talking about the amount of graphics
that was being rendered in that game
I know there's just no way like they
think if they made a fun little like oh
your ship is flying you know I'm saying
like you know like 20 pictures on the
ship flying or doing something okay
speaking of that yeah what I can't stand
is what they should have is during the
loading screen when you're going like I
wish you you should be able to do stuff
at the point
Oh like you're in the menu that is like
you know it lands then you like it
flashes you back then you go back again
yeah you know bravotv time you do it for
like one second what's cool though
what's what's cool about a destiny to to
is to do to do um you don't happen to go
to orbit to go somewhere else now you
can pull up the map and just go
somewhere else right original ruler yeah
originally I've heard they were gonna
try to make it more seamless like do you
go to a hub station then you just go
everywhere I'm like but you know I'm
sure it's it's tough I mean there are a
limited technology yeah well even with
that though going someplace else see the
orbit wasn't necessarily about traveling
from place to place to orbit was a place
that you meet up with your fire right
yeah so that's what that's a nice oh
well what they're talking about is like
if if you're doing this story you know
you can go from that mission you're done
with it you can pull up your map and go
to the next one and you don't have to
like orbit sucked because that would
take so much we play the game it takes
well that's why I'm sorry that's why I
get frustrated that because when you
like factor in the amount of time you're
on loading screens or going to the show
you should have showed our stats you
know what that's what you should do
right now is you know on the screen look
how long each of us have played know
about that there yeah that would be
really I mean my parents are prize
don't understand it
yeah but I don't want to show that well
we know I'm gonna play all let's show it
oh yeah fine right now I always see the
KD as you won't see the KD
oh I will see if I've improved cuz I
don't know if I know you know I'll see
to see this we used a [ __ ] cuz when we
were definitely play know when we played
I don't get a kill
I know we play trials is to our
commander will you play files you would
complain because we weren't getting
kills and then like you didn't remember
you didn't snipe it first you you did
you're a lot better than you oh yeah you
yeah you're so much we didn't play pvp
you didn't use sniper rifles you didn't
use different ones do my family I gotta
kill what do you think about the might
now assists count towards your KD oh you
like that but I had to save for the
three amigos are gonna count down nice
how far away we are from when we did
this today but I think I think they've
killed you it's like this I oh yeah you
get yeah but you being Griffin I will
say like that was the hand we do get a
lot of assists yeah I mean especially
because dope cuz I mean maybe it's not
always justified but like Coco get like
a tuna kill and like what's your secret
man just tell you what you see you see
like what's funny is when I came over
you know I had my I have my girlfriend
okay we're on vacation I took time to go
over to Steve's apartment I was just
watching a play out yeah and I showed
you some of my tips intro is the thing
with his trip lines he knows
strategically where like above a door
he'll know I'm worth walking he's gonna
come out so he'll place a right above
the door I'm like how'd you know that
but also his aim is really good I mean
he's very are you got smart of a monitor
like you have a special game that's not
a hand-eye coordination
he's a feeder
Jamie I just noticed like I mean it's
common sense any smaller screen and the
monitors are really sharp but any
smaller screen it's all in front of you
and you can see I don't have to like
move my eyes to see something in myself
I'm doing this and that's just enough
time for me to get killed you know
because they hit you last reaction time
right so that that a small monitor helps
a lot just because yeah I don't have to
use my per if like that and I don't have
to move my eyelids oh you don't think
big screen is the way to go no although
all the players latency how's the watch
spring all the pro players
yes soil monitors yeah well the bigger
ones have latency issues too so they're
down screen really above the Samsung
Samsung they have a game room oh yeah we
do so much candies Han K and what I do
with my hand cannon is you know a lot of
people stop and they try to stop and
just aim I've got good at straight
because he was taking Simon's I like him
for shooting my girl Andre side-to-side
you how do you learn that but also
you're good at jumping I mean you're
just yeah don't you do jumping hand
gunshots but you know you know what I'm
talking about what I've been doing
recently though as I've been using bones
of a oh and then I put better because
you can show both you can triple because
I should you can get four if I have
triple jump on it gives you a fourth one
but I do the better control so it makes
them it's it's triple jump when I get
more distance well I will always but
more than that but more than should we
jump in ladder
yeah he's the deadliest with his with
his golden I mean he almost never misses
a show
I think his mom sounds very nice
seriously it's it's a little creepy
ya know how do you know last one
standing
my golden copper gun
yeah let's hold it people are hard about
golden gun is you don't have you don't
get like a lot of supers and you get a
speed buff
like if you're a storm caller oh yeah
your speak so you can catch up to people
now you're slowly gotten you can what I
do is I as I read the radar and I smell
there's a blue there and I make sure
they're in a spot that's open so even
when they hear that gun go off even if
they're running I know where they're
running - because I just in the my horse
don't worry it's almost like he's
fortune telling because I've seen him
and he'll jump and shoot as the guys
coming out oh my super while I'm in the
air yeah because I'll jump and they they
at that time they'd of it I don't have
my super pop but while I'm in the air
I'll pop the super by the there's Orion
team they don't Amaro and they have to
figure out where's this junk coming it's
tiny and it's a two-night right that's
one thing too because you can hear the
supers and yeah just run away yeah
frightened so that's why you got what
you own then you go because people that
pop it and just expect people to be here
they're not gonna be there me I'm gonna
run away from it
or if I'm playing it's going nuts but
golden guns one of the Opie
if gold does not the most powerful it's
God you know as I don't the most part no
no because because Golden Gun still be
strong car yeah yeah shut down the story
one shot no the bombs better than stone
collar because it was yeah if a stone
color if you're the top anova bomb it
was thrown contact they're gonna die but
it's but the thing is here this is one
you're you're assuming you're assuming
someone's got a super pumped that's not
how it works in the game in the game
when a super spot though most time
people don't have their super if no one
has their super and you got a storm
collar and in one verse six yeah I've
done it you can go in and wipe out the
entire team I can I have enough time to
and this you are still gonna super still
going I can still with all settled into
the other side of Matt Ryan kill them
again and the thing is storm caller has
blink there's better right any time we
system because they'll blink though and
it the blink isn't it I just don't think
it's like the storm cars you get more
kills with it well say literally don't
be like I'll be like the Ale it's like
two games I'm here three times you have
70 abrahamic damage and you have a
recovery buff so yeah as a storm caller
even if you're getting team shot it
takes forever to get that [ __ ] down
Golden Gun you don't get a buff if
someone shoots you near if you get that
shot killed you know it's a one-shot
kill and it's good but it's very
situational you got to do it at the
right time this is a baller I can just
do it craziest wall that kills because
of strong we got seventh pillar seventh
column which way to kill seven yeah okay
in all you do in skirmish there is a
time where I used before they they they
nerfed the storm color time a little bit
it's still red I guess but when it was
ridiculously high
I killed an entire team they respond on
the other side of the map and I went to
the other side of the map and killed
again with the storm colors in one super
so my amy debuff flat thank you they
need to know that's a table it that was
episode huh yeah that was
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]